knapp 100 tage krieg in der ukraine und
auch heute wollen wir uns ansehen wie
denn gerade im osten des landes die
militärische lage aussieht und wir
schaffen uns noch mal ganz kurz einen
überblick nachdem im norden ja schon
seit einigen wochen nicht mehr gekämpft
wird ist hier im osten tatsächlich die
lage dramatisch wir vor einem rund um
die stadt wäre die letzte oder vorletzte
großstadt die noch in der region luhansk
von ukrainischen truppen gehalten wird
und wir haben neue aufnahmen die uns
zeigen wie denn die straßenkämpfe dort
zehn mehr oder eben vor sich gehen diese
aufnahmen sind von einer ukrainischen
helmkamera das heißt eine ukrainischer
soldat selber sozusagen die das gefilmt
wie er hier gegen die russischen
invasoren kämpft und wir sehen hier eben
diese straßenkämpfe gesehen also dass er
mit seinen leuten hier sich verstecken
muss das ist schweres feuer gibt aus
allen richtungen da vorne übrigens was
wir in der mitte denen das ist das hotel
mir ein hotel in dem ja auch im jahr
2019 übernachtet habe dieses hotel wurde
als angriffspunkt genommen von
tschetschenischen kämpfern die dort in
die stadt eingefallen sind und von dort
aus sozusagen ihren widerstand auf ihre
indien ihren vorsprung ihren vorstoss in
die stadt eingeleitet haben wir sehen
also dass die ukrainer hierunter unter
feuer sind dass sie versuchen irgendwie
sich durch die gassen zu bewegen und
irgendwie gegen diese absolute übermacht
an wir hatten uns schon gesagt an
tschetschenischen kämpfern an wagner
soll dann sollten an regulären
russischen soldaten dort irgendwie stand
zu halten wir wissen mittlerweile dass
hat auch die ukraine eingeräumt dass
über 70 prozent der stadt verloren sind
die ukraine kämpfen leider auch dort
relativ auf verlorenem posten ziehen
sich immer weiter zurück und die russen
rücken in dieser großstadt über 100.000
einwohner ehemals weiter vor
apropos russen diese aufnahmen sind aus
der region kreativ das ist ganz in der
nähe dort und das besondere eigentlich
ist die flagge die wir hier sehen denn
vielleicht wenn wir uns das mal ansehen
diese flagge ist die oppositions flagge
von russischen oppositionellen das heißt
wir haben es hier mit russen zu tun die
für die ukraine kämpfen und dort gegen
putins armee vorrücken also eine flagge
die erst vor wenigen wochen ein guter
vor wenigen monaten eingeführt wurde zu
kriegsbeginn und über die sich dann
einige russische oppositionelle geeinigt
haben dass das sozusagen die flagge ist
des freien russlands des gerechten
russlands und diese menschen männer hier
haben sich tatsächlich dem kampf der
ukraine gegen die russische armee
angeschlossen sind also selber dabei als
russen andere russin im schlachtfeld zu
töten
ein ganz interessante grafik wurde
nochmal jetzt veröffentlicht und ich
finde die müssen wir uns mal ansehen wir
sehen hier oben links in der ecke sehen
wir das gebiet was derzeit von russland
gehalten wird in der ukraine und
ukrainische aktivisten haben und das ist
wirklich ganz beeindruckend mal geguckt
was würde das bedeuten diese diese größe
dieses gebiet in anderen ländern und wir
gucken uns beispielsweise mal dass hier
in der mittleren das ist ziemlich gut zu
erkennen dass sich italien und wir sehen
dass über die hälfte italiens wäre dann
dieses gebiet besetzt sozusagen unter
kontrolle ist und hier ganz rechts haben
wir deutschland und wir sehen auch hier
das gebiet im süden wir sehen also das
ganz ganz bayern und auch ganz baden
württemberg und auch mehrere weitere
weitere bundesländer und wir haben uns
auch hier luxemburg mit dabei komplett
von russland besetzt wären würde es eben
ja sozusagen dieses gebiet diese der
dieser diesem gebiet in deutschland
besetzen seien auch hier unten ganz gut
zu sehen ganz österreich die ganze
schweiz ist etwa die größe ganz
ex-jugoslawien die südliche hälfte von
großbritannien und ganz tschechien
slovakei also riesige gebiete die von
russland bereits besetzt wurden und die
gerade deshalb sehr entscheidend sind
für die ukraine diese versucht
zurückzugewinnen das war um eine
perspektive zu kriegen über welche mega
gebiete wir tatsächlich sprechen um die
gerade jetzt in der ukraine gekämpft
wird
wir wollen uns eine weitere sache
ansehen und zwar dieses video was
erstmal vielleicht gar nicht so
auffällig ist die lächelt ein
ukrainischer soldat in die kamera das
entscheiden dass das was im hintergrund
sehen das sind die ersten aufnahmen der
m109 das ist ein amerikanisches
selbstfahrer fette ein
artilleriegeschütz sozusagen das sich
schnell bewegen kann was bereits jetzt
in der ukraine angekommen ist dieses
soll aus norwegen stammen mit munition
aus den usa das entscheidende ist dass
tatsächlich immer mehr länder aus dem
westen bis auf deutschland schwere
waffen in die ukraine liefern um eben
diesen kampf dort irgendwie aufrecht zu
erhalten um wir haben es eben gesagt den
vorstoß der russischen armee aufzuhalten
wir sehen am ende des videos dann auch
und zwar jetzt wie hier
ist richtig der 4 diese 109 stehen
dieser geschützte stehen und dann gleich
parallel feuern auf die russischen
besatzer die eben weiter im osten
vorrücken dass also ein jetzt ist das
also ein geschütz amerikanischer bauart
was allerdings aus norwegen geliefert
wurde und was jetzt dort im einsatz ist
und wir sehen wie dringend tatsächlich
auch weiterhin die ukraine dieses
schweren waffen auch endlich aus
deutschland braucht um die russen im
osten aufzuhalten